four o' everyone we're going to
start
ready welcome to this meeting of Baba
District Council cabinet I'm councelor
John Ward acting leader of Baba District
Council and I'll be chairing this
meeting May I first of all remind you of
some domestic arrangements please ensure
that microphones are turned off when not
in use that you do not interrupt other
speakers that if you are attending the
meeting to speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave please ensure your your mobile
phones are on silent or Switched Off
additionally we'll be using EV voting
for this meeting on the modern. goov app
I'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being filmed by
entering this meeting as a speaker you
are also consenting to being recorded by
the council and to the possible use of
those images
and all recordings um uh images and
sound recordings for webcasting and all
training purposes the council members of
the public and the Press May record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the Press are not
lawfully
excluded before I move to the agenda um
uh I just like to say and you were
probably expecting Council Buzzy to be
chairing the meeting today and it was
the intention that he would be doing so
unfortunately he is not well and may
well be having to go to hospital this
afternoon so um on behalf of the cabinet
I do wish him uh all the best and we are
thinking of him it does mean that um a
couple of the items that were due to be
presented by him will be presented by me
so unfortunately you're going to be
hearing a lot more from me than either I
or possibly some of you would have liked
but uh that can't be helped so moving on
then item one apologies for
absence thank you chair we have
apologies from councelor David Busby and
councelor Helen d
thank you item two to receive
Declarations of pecuniary other
registerable or non-reg interests by
members are there any to declare
members nope item three then paper BCA
2331 to confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on the 4th of December
2023 so if um I go to the the minutes we
have
on the pack here um we now going through
from the minutes from page five anyone
have anything on that page
six page
[Music]
seven page
eight and finally page nine so if there
are no questions or comments on on the
minutes then uh regarding points of
accuracy may I have a proposal for the
minutes please councelor mcra and a
second
Council
saw right um can we conduct the vote
please for for the
minutes thank you chair that vote is now
in progress thank
you
thank you chair that is six votes for
and one abstention so that's carried
thank
you okay then so moving on um go back to
my other document
here we've now got uh to item four to
receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme none received chair item five
questions by councilors none received
chair and item six matters referred by
the overview and scrutiny or joint audit
and standards committees there are no
matters referred chair item seven
forthcoming decisions list members of
the cabinet um I hope you've all had a
chance to look at the forthcoming
decisions list um do you have any
questions on
anything great if not we'll move on then
so the next item is uh now actually what
I want to do sorry is to alter a couple
of items and I do have the prerogative
to do that I'm going to bring item nine
forward uh in front of item uh eight um
and uh this is because I know one or two
people might want to leave um and uh so
we we'll go straight into the
substantive item item nine on the
parking charges so it's paper BCA 2333
free and charges for 24 to 25 parking
charges um so in my capacity as leader
of the C I would like to introduce this
report um but uh before doing so I will
say that we do have um Mark M our
director for operations here and also
Matt Smith parking services manager
they're also members of the finance team
who are here for later reports um should
should we need to include them in in
answering any questions so without
further
Ado I will now introduce report BCA 2333
to Cabinet fees and charges for the car
parking
firstly I do want to acknowledge that
this is a very emotive and divisive
subject probably the most divisive we
have ever had it always has been our
parking service is budgeted to cost the
council approximately £ 427,000 this
year although the current C two data is
showing a bit of an underspend but more
on this later the cost is set to
increase further next year and given a
budget gap of at least 1.8
million in the current year the council
cannot continue this level of subsidy if
it wants to deliver its approved car
parking strategy and indeed to continue
delivering other essential services for
our residents and
communities I need to stress that this
report only considers options and makes
recommendations for the decision-making
process giving due consideration to
engagement expediency and
risk we've considered several
options Outsourcing of car pars to an
external provider not varying the
charges and varying the
charges Outsourcing to another provider
has been rejected based on factors such
as diminished control of tar setting and
road traffic order requirements
distracting focus on uh on contract
management and contract versus value
versus strategy delivery and also
incompatibility between on street and
off- Street enforcement delivery which
won't lead to any perceived savings not
varying the charges has been rejected as
this will not help our budget challenges
and will make delivery of the parking
strategy unaffordable and this option
was previously rejected by cabinet in
2021 pending approval of the proposed
approach today officers will meet with
town and Parish councils to discuss
local options ahead of a further report
coming back to Cabinet in April
meanwhile later this month the overview
and scrutiny committee will also
consider the proposal the proposed
approach alongside wider draft budget
proposals I would like to propose the
recommendations in section three that we
carry out engagement on the details of a
revised tariff scheme and present a
proposal to present to the overview and
scret committee for their examination
and advice to
Cabinet finally there are three things
that I want members of the cabinet to
remember financially we have no
realistic option this will despite
protestations to the contrary benefit
the towns in the long run and it is
fair now before before
I move
on
um I proposed this paper I would like a
second to please I have a second
councelor
McCraw um now the way we're going to
conduct this there will be opportunity
for members of the cabinet to ask
questions and later on to debate and I
do want to keep the questions separate
from from debate so we just really focus
on questions after members of the
cabinet have asked questions I know uh
obviously this has generated a lot of
interest which is why we have so many
members present today which is unusual
for a cabinet meeting but I will then
invite other members of the council if
they have questions there are a lot of
you here and I'll restrict it to one
question per person otherwise we will
just not get through everything and I'm
sure we'll be able to cover all of the
issues um that you wish to raise through
one question per person and there will
be questions please um apart from
councelor Owen who has asked in advance
that she may be allowed to say a few
words and I've have granted her that um
uh to be able to do that so I'll come to
councilor Owen in due course so firstly
members of the cabinet do you have any
questions on the paper in front of you
today councilor Sally Davis um I'm I'm
looking at uh paragraph 4.5 about the
targeted engagement and I can um with
SRE Lam and chel medist um are we
thinking that we would um extend that um
consultation to um people in the more to
the east of
Baba I I think um the the consultation
engagement process is is going to be a
tight time scale um the the direct uh
engagement in terms of talking to the
specific U parishes that are affected by
tariffs um will take place but it it is
quite um proper that we do ask other
communities throughout the district to
feedback any comments they might have
whether it's uh formally through their
Parish councils or informally um from
any member of the public with u within
any of our communities um and we will be
encouraging that um I I believe that we
do need to hear from them all yes
councilor Derek Davis yeah um could I
ask will all the papers that we have
seen in the past all the reports that
point out the reasons why we need to do
this and and the surveys that have being
carried elsewhere will they be made
available to all the towns and parishes
so that they have the full information
rather than just relying on hea the um
the previous cabinet papers uh that
relate to the the previous cabinet
decision um the parking strategy that
was approved by cabinet all of these are
public domain papers um which uh are
published on on our website um as part
of cabinet minutes over the past few
years um but we can certainly uh make
sure that they are specifically made
available to to any Parish Council that
that wishes to to have them
yeah Council
Carter thank you um just for
transparency really um the cost of the
425,000 this year um is there a break
down of that that can be shared with
everybody yes there he is um and and we
could do that straight away actually um
Alysa would you like to put that on on
the screen
um
uh so if you just bear with me uh I'm
going
to get some detail here because
important that
um we have the right narrative so um
this is going to be scrolled through um
gradually but you'll see that the this
this is from the the budget as it was
set earlier in this financial year um
the the current Quarter Two is showing
some differences and I'll I'll come on
to those um as as we approach them but
but basically we have the the overall uh
net cost is42
7,485 you'll see the employee cost there
of uh just under £440,000
um and uh those costs include uh a 0.5
full-time equivalent of a car parking
manager and22 full-time equivalent of
admin support and these employee costs
include salaries pension contributions
National Insurance Etc and and various
mileages so those are those employee
costs so you i' like to scroll down a
bit further here we have the the the
bulk of the costs which are the
operational costs um you'll see that uh
the the largest chunk of that are the
business rates at just under £300,000
um when I talk about the the current
quarter 2 position I'll I'll um I'll
speak about that in a moment um there
are a number of other things there um
software licenses rela to my permit um
obviously electricity cost uh we have um
uh equipment tools um costs in there um
this is a capital cost for um
uh various upgrades to machine signage
that sort of thing um another work
following the the um findings of the
parking strategy that we approved um I
will say at the moment these this band
hasn't come to fruition um and so it's
it's quite likely that that will will be
rolled forward and so we come out of
this but if you then scroll down a bit
further please thank you enforcement
enforcement is carried out by West
suffer Council and it Bar
Council um we pay them just under 87,000
for that enforcement activity um they
collect on our behalf just over
62,000 so therefore there's a net
difference of about 26,000 £4,000 sorry
which we then have to pay to those
councils uh as net cost of
enforcement um we have uh in terms of
our corporate overheads um we have a
total budget cost of corporate overheads
of about or just over7 million pound
they have to be a portioned uh um
correctly across all of our services and
uh just over 1% of that is allocated to
parking that's the 73,000 you'll see
there okay Alysa and if we then look
further down this is then the income
that we can net off against those costs
that totals as you'll see um just under
146,000 um most of that is is the car
parking income from the long stay
parking charges and there's some further
income from permits and seasoned tickets
that um residents can can apply for um
and one or two other small costs there
so as as I said the the quarter 2
position is showing um an improvement on
that and obviously we won't know the
full details of for the whole year until
the outturn is published um in the
summer but um as I've said there is that
uh the £50,000
on that um that item earlier on is
likely to be rolled over we are looking
at a reduction probably of a similar
amount of money of business
rates um so
around about £100,000 possibly at the
moment uh could come off that 427
bringing that down to
327 so that is the current
breakdown if we can keep that uh
actually probably no we can take we can
take that off the screen might have to
come back again but is that okay
councelor
Carter any other questions from cabinet
members
okay I will now move over to other
members um to ask questions and I will
invite councelor Owen
first if you'd like
to say a few words yeah
sorry no no no so you can sit
yeah thank you for giving me this
opportunity to to have my say Our Town
Center is healthy recovery from the
challenging trading conditions of the
past few years our businesses are
adapting and our High Street is changing
like many towns and cities across the
country to an increasingly experienced
based economy Subway's Rich Heritage
office offer also gives our town a
diverse experience for residents and
visitors this new experience economy
benefits greatly from free 3-hour
parking as Town centers dwell times
increase it is reassuring for our
businesses customers to know they they
can relax and spend more time money with
our Town's
businesses in quarter 3 2023 sub vacancy
rate is is at its lowest level in five
years currently just under
4% of of all Town commercial units are
vacant 10% vacancy is considered healthy
and is well below the current national
average of the high streets
13.9% so we're really low we're 4% of
vacant
shops in subby Town we've got
72.6% of independent businesses the
national chains we've got
15.6% charity
5.4% and so on we had we welcomed 15 new
new businesses to sub
town and that is because of our 3H hour
3our free parking for a customers is
often cited as a contributive factor in
choosing suby for
businesses I've got a list of them here
but I won't go through them all okay
closures we lost two Banks and and that
the HSB and Barkley's glassw closed
undergoing a residential commercial so
even though we're we're lost a couple we
haven't we've gained so
many and that is because of free
parking we are we want to be we don't
want to follow other towns we want to be
elite I try I go into sub four or five
times a
week and because it's free because I can
and because I can go and have a cup of
coffee so I'm helping them businesses
but I will not be going into town four
or five times a week if I cannot if I
have to pay for car parking thank you
ever so much for letting me speak
Sean okay then any other
members uh right sorry
um sorry councelor Clover sorry my M
went blank councelor
Clover be the right hand one is that not
working try that
one thank you the um um this is an e um
relates to the economy so I think it
probably should be addressed to the
member of the cabinet for finance but
it's very simple it's really has any um
assessment been done on the impact that
um these charges will have on the
economy of these all of these towns and
Villages uh Hadley suby lavenant and all
the surrounding Villages as well uh and
if that assessment has yet to be done
why hasn't it been done um um
we the um impact on various communities
I think it's it's very anecdotal
whatever evidence there is but um in
terms of the uh all of the U various
communities uh I'm not quite sure what
you you're you're trying to to get out
there but um we know that um uh from
work that's done elsewhere that uh there
is very little proof that uh small
changes to parking charges has any
discernable impact on economic viability
of towns um councelor Owen has uh said
that the subre vacancy rate is is 4% I
must say I was unaware that it's that
low um the latest figure I had was
7.8% but um uh which which is good but
what we do know is that Stone Market has
a similar vacancy rate to suby that has
car parking charges
um so it it that's a a quite clear local
example of where um it doesn't have any
material
impact um I don't Council saw did you
want to come back on something
that
um it is true that uh there is very
little um data around to prove that free
parking does increase uh footfall or
that charges
uh decrease football um as part of my
preparation for this um debate I uh
spoke with uh people and places who are
um do a lot of work with Market towns
and are actually the
lga's um partner in in town center uh
work and they have
done studies in 30 Market towns and they
have have said and are willing to go on
the record that um the the actual
criteria the number one and number two
criteria are
convenience and
accessibility and the park that charging
is uh not regarded uh in the same way as
those first two criteria um although it
is the third criteria and it is true
that uh we are an outlier there are
there are no uh districts in suffk who
have free car parking and there are very
few because I've looked there are very
few district councils with Market towns
who do not
charge thank you Council sa can I come
back very briefly then the uh research
by deo's show that it does have an
impact and in the deo's research 60% the
top item of what people want from their
Town centers was free car parking 60%
wanted that and as for Stone Market if
you look at Stone Market would you say
it's got the vibrancy that sub has or
laum or Hadley there's a reason why
these towns are so attractive so and
that is because of the free parking
thank you for that any other questions
from any who would like Council grandon
and then
um councel Smith Council gr and Council
Smith Council
be thank you um can you explain how it
can be justified that you're using the
2021 cabinet decision uh to not allow
the option of no
change um have I understood it correctly
that you're using um a decision made in
2021 to not include the option of and no
change to parking fees to be included in
the range of
options um have I understood that
correctly if so can you then explain or
can someone explain how that that can
stand and can it be debated with this
current there's a you've got a
completely new cabinet here so you
should not be using in my view an old
cabinet decision when there's been an C
since with a completely different
demographic so please could you explain
how this can be justified we're not um
following on from the old cabinet
decision we are starting aresh and this
is the first um paper that that kicks
off that fresh process um there will be
another paper that will have um proposed
tariffs that will come to Cabinet in in
April which will supersede the Tariff
paper that um was approved by cabinet
three years ago what we we had three
options to look at um and uh as part of
this um and we have a recommended option
and and this is usual for for cabinet
and Council papers that um there are a
number of options and there's a
recommended option um and for
completeness the three options were um
don't do anything uh revise the tariffs
or Outsource those were the three ones
we looked at and this paper now based on
on look having assess those three and
coming back with a recommendation and
we're here today to debate that
recommendation and either approve or not
that recommendation so may I just ask
when when was the option
of no change to the current um tariff uh
thrown out um by well as as part of the
um uh the work that we've done in
putting this paper together so has that
been debated by the current cabinet uh
we we've talked about it in in cabinet
briefings and that's the way we we do
these things with with uh cabinet papers
and then we come back to the meeting
with a paper and a proposed
recommendation and and for completeness
we always uh highlight those alternative
options that have been rejected as part
of the process putting the paper
together it sounds to me that it was
rejected before it came to the current
cabinet no is that correct no no not at
all no this is this is for this this uh
this paper is a new paper for this
cabinet so the current cabinet
debated um the option of no change we
didn't we discussed informally that's
that was part of the process within the
cabinet process or outside the cabinet
process
Within okay any other questions is that
minuted I can point out the minutes on
that yeah can yeah I'll get the monitor
officer to explain things clear thank
you chair so just um to actually you
know just clarify things at the moment
what we have is a decision but taken
back in 2021 which um decision there was
to implement charges that that de
decision was then a decision was then
taken to postpone that just to postpone
it until after October
2021 at the moment and before any other
decision is taken that is still the the
um recom you know the resolution in
situe if you like what we are just
discussing today is with um cabinet are
looking at three options and um they are
deciding on those three options which
one they're going to go forward with and
consult on and the decision will be
taken today to to decide an option and
go forward and consult with all Parish
councils on that option so it is based
though on a decision made in
2021 that decision is still in situe at
the moment until such times as today
that Council make another recommend uh
resolution but they haven't done so yet
we're still in discussion so as as
monitoring officer Could you um advise
um whether it's possible to bring BR
back that option for the cabinet to
discuss is that a possible it's not an
option on the table today the options
are the three in front of you and that's
the one which whatever cabinet decide on
today will supersede the decision that
was taken back in
2021 okay councilor
Smith thank you um you said the
consultation is going to be broad across
the dist across the the district it's um
further east and everything uh what
about further south in Essex because is
there any possibility of Consulting
with um visitors to subury from Essex
because a lot of our towns for comes
from across the border is there any way
of including them um yeah I I I do
understand that and I have heard this um
suggestion before um Essex residents
don't pay any B council tax they don't
benefit from our services all all of the
communities in baba um do pay pay and
contribute and they're the ones that
could stand to lose um should should we
have to cut back Services unnecessarily
which is why we uh want to make sure we
do hear from as many of them as possible
wherever they are um whether they are um
suby obviously or or or Hadley or lavim
or whether they are East bergold um or
indeed um shortly um and um perhaps also
um places like Pinewood and spron
Council Riley because I'm sure they
might have an interesting view on on
this um so the the we
can't expand it wider to Mid suffk or
west suffk and the residents from both
of those districts that that may go to
Lavenham or or sbur um and neither could
we to uh to essic that that would just
make the whole process
unwieldy
councelor
beer thank you Mr chairman um could I
just point out that the councelor
opposite remarked that um we were here
debating well unfortunately we're not
here debating or at least us members
over here enough in allow to debate we
can only ask
questions um my question to you is to do
with the consultation I'm sure you're
aware that um there has been an online
petition and and that is well over 3,000
and that there was on the market here in
subury on Saturday uh a, plus people who
signed petition so we're on the figure
of four well over 4,000 near four and a
half my question to you
is will you be
allowing because I believe we have to
now take this to a full council meeting
because we're over a thousand which I've
seen some although I can't find it I'll
be quite honest there uh that it has to
come to full Council will you allow a
debate
transparent of all members who were
elected in May
203 to come to this chamber sit in this
chamber hear all the facts and debate
which is what the lady opposite said
that she was hoping she's going to do we
can't at the moment and we can voice our
opinions and we can vote a a vote at the
end that is three and transparent of all
members I'll just hand over to the the
monitoring officer but um you're you're
right Council beer the Constitution does
state that if a petition raises over a
thousand votes it has to be debated by
full Council so the answer to your
question is quite simple yes but I'll uh
let the monitoring officer uh clarify a
bit further um yes thank you chair so
the petitions process clearly sets out
how we deal with petitions where we
receive over a thousand signatures
because that petition has now reached
that threshold um it doesn't finish
until the 31st of January so the next
available council meeting will be the
February council meeting and that
petition will come forward to full
Council it's prescribed in the petitions
process how it will be dealt with I
think there's a maximum of 30 minutes
but again that's always down to the
chair's discretion
and if there's a good debate that chair
the chair could decide to extend that
but at the end of that there's some
options which clearly states in the and
and you'll actually vote whether you
agree with the petition don't agree with
the petition want to note the petition
or refer it to somewhere else so there's
four options that Council will have the
opportunity to vote
on chairman could I just quickly come
back on that point because you you did
it in your open remarks say that you
were
extending us all to asked only one
question because there quite a few here
and I do understand that we want to be
here all night but could I be assured
after hearing what the monitor officer
said that it will be more than 30
minutes because this is something that
fundamentally the people uh of Baba and
I say Baba are really angry that this is
happening they say it happening behind
closed doors they say it that the
democracy counc you made a point the
Democracy of elected members are not
having the opportunity to speak and
that's what I want to be assured 30
minutes will not allow us all to
speak that is at the discretion of the
the chair of the council so you'll have
to ask councelor malvi that I can't give
you that
guarantee right um councilor
Riley I just wanted to check that I
actually understand something that we
have um income of £40,000
and we have
costs uh approximately £425,000
is my understanding correct if you wish
to go and eliminate the deficit you're
going to have to increase your income by
a factor of
three yeah yes so the question is how
are we going to get 425 how we going to
get to 425,000
costs approximate out of from an income
of a third of that at
140,000 first you're focusing on this uh
these numbers that I I gave you um these
are only this the 427,000 uh which is
the uh projected budgetary net cost of
the car parts there's only just one
element that that um forms part of our
budget um we we're
not our proposal for raising additional
Revenue through car park short-term car
parking tariffs is not just to focus on
these numbers here it is part of a wider
package of measures we're undertaking to
try to close our budget Gap it is that
budget Gap number that is the important
one not
this but Mr chairman we
respect C poy is costing 425,000
including
overheads and we have existing income of
140,000 so you've either got to bump up
one by a factor of three or else you got
continue subsidizing the car parks at
another level well certainly we we will
be looking when we come to Revis The
Proposal revised tariff scheme uh we'll
be looking at what we can um get in
terms of income from from that so that
that that's part of the next process
Council Ry um any other questions
councelor Ma and then counc thank you C
thank you Council Ward um I'm not
allowed to comment on your last am I
allowed to comment on your last answer
I'd like you to ask a question please um
I assume want to get to Cabinet debate
on this because it is a cabinet meeting
yes but I don't actually agree with what
you you said about the revenue um my
question is in 2018 and it is in print
the vision for sub sbur states that free
parking is the attraction to Sudbury has
that vision for Sudbury been um altered
since 2018
please the vision for subur in 2018 um
said a lot of things um and what I've
heard everything that you've said about
I can't hear you I'm sorry sorry I've
heard everything you've said uh or
that's been said so far about um sodbury
and uh the the potential benefit of of
this but we I bring it back to the the
primary reason for looking at this and
that is we have no choice we have to
maximize our income and I'll be talking
about fees uh other fees and charges um
uh in the next item we have to uh for
our discretionary services and parking
is a discretionary service they have it
has to be um pay at the point of use we
just just simply do not have funding or
income from other sources to pay for
everything we
do all of our other discretionary
Services have to pay their way I'm sure
I'm sure you won't let me come back but
the one thing I will say is there are
lots of things that I actually pay for
through my council tax to babber that I
don't actually benefit for from and
everyone is exactly the same those are
the statutary services but we we're
talking about discretionary Services
council tax is less than 30% of our
funding yes I know but there are other
things that I pay for that um
through that I don't benefit
from thank you chair um I'd like to ask
about the targeted engagement and
consultation exercise proposed in
paragraph 4.5 of the paper um I see that
views and evidence will be sought which
will inform proposed variations to
tariffs and off Street r road traffic
orders what I'd like to ask is can a
consultation be free fair and open to a
full range of answers if you're only
asking about tariffs being varied thank
you and well the the answer is is yes
but um I I will ask um Mark M to come up
uh to provide some more detail about the
consultation that we're
proposing hello thank you uh sorry thank
you chair we we we haven't put the full
details together of Engagement obviously
we're waiting for this meeting to see
whether the recommendation is actually
approved but we've started to have a
look at what that engagement might look
look like we do feel that consultations
already been carried out as part of our
car parking strategy across the district
and that um and that you see that figure
has been represented um broad General
support for car parking charging as part
of the overall system Fair charging
there um we do feel that the engagement
has got to be targeted and we do feel
it's got to be put with the context of
the overall budget position and
challenges we face but we do feel there
are opportunities in um if we go forward
with implementing charging to actually
make some improvements as well we know
that on Street enforcement is a
challenge and if on Street enforcement
is carried out um to a better standard
um then that can help to relieve some
parking issues and TR traffic issues um
in our in our towns and we do think
there are options around um permits and
the way they are um administered
delivered that can assist and help as
well and we are open-minded to working
with uh the County Council on residents
parking zones in the future and other
whole system um opportunities around
parking really but um that we really
want the engagement to understand and
inform the proposals of what the the
local issues are what's going to work
what's not going to work as opposed to
just moving beyond the it it can't
happen really so we have started to
engage with um towns for Hadley for
example I've got a a meeting with the
Clark in Hadley um later this week which
was rescheduled from last week and I've
met with sbin laum already as well and
we will if if this recommendation is is
approved then we will look at that
engagement and agree what the next step
is on
that supplement yes very quickly thank
you for your answer can I take it then
that the probable answers of the town
and Parish councils you're going to
consult which will be extremely negative
regarding varied um fees that those
objections will simply be
discounted I don't know if I sorry if I
respond to that um I don't know that
they would necessarily just be dis
counted but interestingly so far it's
not overridingly negative the response
back that we've had so far there are
some elements of solving parking issues
as part of this as well if you move
beyond the um the the charging just
can't happen there's a number of
underlying parking issues in town as
well and and getting tariffs correct can
help to improve some of those issues as
well and uh yeah as part of this
discussion we'll also be asking what the
alternative is and what is being
proposed about where savings would be
made um alternatively and what services
people would like to see um changed or
reduced in order to um make up the
deficit
effectively any other
questions in which case we'll move on to
Cabinet debate members of the cabinet
would anyone like to say anything at
this
stage yes thank you couna yeah thank you
chair
we have seen and has been demonstrated
by the disappointment and angle bu by
sub Town Council in their recent egm of
the 2nd of January leaving me in no
doubt that the proposal set on three
major car Parks all owned by Baba
District Council would have on the town
and its ability to be a w wi Place
accessible for Shoppers for free short
state parking indeed many people have
traveled as far as brain tree Mark in
Essex as well as rural areas near to
suby as a car is vital for travel as
public transport is a scarce and
limiting option below wishing to physic
Market Town Ina it can also be
attributed to hatle and what can be
currently provided for short stay
Shoppers I deeply feel that any move now
we in the near future to end free
parking at paper car Parks will be
detrimental shops especially smaller
shops which are independent they
desperately need Customs for remaining
place in the immediate period following
the covid-19 pandemic and for a CO
postco recovery to take any stronger and
fulfilled effect these charges would my
deeply held view affect shoer behavior
and limit time spent in the town centers
of
B even if you could Implement scheme
where the first hour of shopping was
free of charge in a town center such a
suffy time spent visiting each shop
would be drastically reduced and only
essential shop
would be
prioritized so to allow fre hours a free
of charge gives that briefing space
during the pandemic and would receive
the cust and it my intent therefore if
we come to a position of the fre options
that have been uh discussed here to uh
keep free uh shopping at three hours for
short stay Shoppers in our Market towns
and keep our economy working as well as
it has been thank
you
okay thank you everyone thank you
Council Potter doeses anyone else wish
to say anything Council
Carter thank you
um yes so there are many points of this
that I cannot agree with um mainly being
due to the area of which I represent is
going to be dramatically affected by
this no matter what is said um and it
will affect it for a number of reasons
the High Street and our independent
businesses that were were mentioned are
still recovering from the effects of
covid um so we recently won the um town
of the year uh many of our unique
selling points and one of them being the
the free parking it does attract people
it's not only a benefit for residents
but we speak to people within within B
without looking further a field and they
will come to subur and they will support
suby and the reason that they do that is
because of the free parking and I
imagine it's the same in the same in
Hadley um the
recommendations in front of us I I can't
really agree with either um uh 3.1 it
states that um there's going to be an
engagement within the for Parish
councils which I do understand but I
don't agree with I think it would be
beneficial to speak to those further a
field and I think that the information
that you would get from them would be
that they do shop locally rather than to
the outside retail Parks or to the
bigger towns it's because they want to
support the towns um and the incentive
is there to do so the free parking being
a major thing of that um if you're in if
you're in lavenin you're pretty much the
same distance As You Are from subury or
Berry or Stow Market why would you go to
subury when it when it simply isn't as
big you would go there because the free
parking is an incentive and it gives you
time to go for your haircut and for your
meal out and for your shopping and to do
whatever it is that you want to do um
3.2 the second recommendation is just to
discuss the varyan car parking charges
without discussing the option to have it
or to not have it at all which does seem
as suggested before very very
dismissive um the third recommendation
states that it it will go to overview in
scrutiny fantastic it definitely needs
to be scrutinized
um and talking about um car parking
charges and off street car parking I
just have to say as the county counselor
for subur I am inundated all the time
with people saying that the residential
streets are taken up by people who are
parking there and that is only going to
make this worse and we do not have the
room for it and again I lived in Hadley
I know it's very much the same in Hadley
um those living in Angel Street it's a
nightmare you can't park anywhere and
once those once the car parked just
across the street if Chargers come in of
course that's where people are going to
park you straight away
um there is a lot of this that I I
appreciate that we have to find the
money I appreciate that do I think that
affecting the the heart of Babor and the
economy and the people is the right way
to go about finding this
money no no I don't um so I I I
sympathize with the fact that we have to
find the money but I do not agree that
this is the way to go about it and
clearly through petitions and through
counselors speaking to their residents
of whom we are all here to represent
this is not our decision we are voted in
to represent the views of the people
this isn't the way to to go about it and
I think there has to be honesty
transparency because that's what people
want to say okay if you want your free
parking have it but this is where the
money is going to have to come from and
just be honest with people um because
that's what they want and if they make
the decision to lose other things and to
keep this that's their decision and who
are we to tell them
no that's it thank you okay thank you
Council car I've got Council s then
Council MRA uh can we not have so much
clapping please dearo
dear councilor sa um I'm glad that um my
colleague councelor Carter uh rais the
issue of what will we have to do if we
do not
take uh the action on car
parking um I think we as a a council are
in a very difficult position after 13
years of
austerity uh every available lever has
been pulled and I am not particularly
enamored of uh charging for parking but
neither am I in favor of cutting
services that people um desperately need
for example um are grants to Citizens um
advice um we have seen what's happened
at County and there will obviously be
some uh fallback on us because people
are going to expect us to uh provide
services that County aren't and we
can't um our funding and communities
will be at risk our funding on Leisure
Services will be at risk um the work
that we do for for elderly people as
regards uh rural isolation and dementia
are at risk now you know we were put we
were elected to make hard
decisions and currently the budget that
confronts us not just this year but for
the next three years it only gets
worse so I would ask uh counselors to
think very carefully about what they
want their uh services to look like and
whether they are content to just focus
on statutory Services going forwards
because that's what we may be looking
at I don't want to do this um I know
that emotions run very high about
parking but we're not talking here about
airport style charging we are looking at
very reasonable tariffs and um I feel
that uh we should be responsible about
this and think about the total service
we um we give to
Residents um and that's uh all I have to
say at this point Thank you councel saw
in the interest of balance I feel like
clapping but probably better not um I
will then uh go on to council mcra and
then councel Derek
Davis I'm happy to defer to Derek if
he'd like to go first because his hand
did go up before mine all right
no I I think the important thing to
remember here is it's about consultation
it's about it going out to everybody so
that they have that opportunity and the
question I asked earlier is about make
sure they've got all the facts because
it's important we need to know exactly
has been pointed out what what um
because this is part of the bigger
picture of the budget you know what are
you going to lose if we if we don't
introduce reduction in free car parking
you do do we defund the Leisure centers
we've seen what s County Council have
done with the Arts half a million Gone
Gone you know we we're not in a good
situation and exactly as everyone says
we'd rather not have to introduce these
but needs must and we need to look at
the bigger picture and as Markus pointed
out it's not everybody's not not
everybody is against this and obviously
you guys are because of where you're
from and I totally get that but there's
a lot of people there's a lot of
positivity about yeah you know let's
reduce the free parking let's have that
rather than some of the unpalatable
options that are coming I'm glad that
this papers come forward because we
didn't do this last time we didn't put
it out for enough consultation but I
think this time by doing this by putting
it out for consultation we're doing the
right thing thank you thank you thank
you counc councelor
mcra thank you chair um
yeah there are duties we've all got got
them we all know that we're elected uh
to serve our residents and to represent
their views but we've also got a
responsibility and it's our Prime
responsibility to be their
representatives within the council to
work to make the council work and the
prime responsibility of any District or
County Council is to present a balanced
budget each year that is a statutory
requirement we have no option but to do
so so cabinet prepares a budget we get
the officers to work through that now
the recommendations here are not what is
being talked about for the large portion
a lot of people are making assumptions
based upon some previous work done in
2021 and in fact even earlier than that
I can recall consultations in my first
term between 2015 and
2019 the recommendations that are
actually before us uh to this carry out
the engagement with the associated town
and Parish councils I also believe it
should be wider because in fact the
people who do not live in subury Hadley
or laven are in effect and this has been
mentioned in many of the documents I've
seen are in effect subsidizing those
people who do use the car parking no
question about it the car parking is a
nonstatutory
requirement other assumptions being made
are what the car parking charges might
be for example it's stated many times
that we're getting rid of we might be
getting rid the free car
parking that was not the proposal in
2021 it was to reduce it from 3 to 1
hour now I've traveled up and down the
length of this country from the far
north of Scotland down to Cornwall and
I've been for the last few years just
because I'm a nerd photographing car
parking sign charges and all the rest of
it I have photographic evidence and I
can tell you that I have yet to find
anywhere else and by the way I like to
go to market towns I like places like
subury and Hadley I like places where
the pubs are nice and comfy not dir
dirty great chains was that giving too
much away never mind um the point I
making is I'm these are the places I go
to I've yet to find anywhere that gives
any free car parking and certainly not
at the level that was previously
proposed Deborah has mentioned
reasonable charges and by the way they
are or they were reasonable and I would
have thought by the time this has been
through o and S and they've made their
recommendations they would also be
reasonable because they're reasonable
people as are indeed all of us point I'm
making here is nobody is this is not
happening in isolation uh every business
and every Council has been facing cost
pressures in the last few years massive
cost pressures in fact I doubt there is
a single business providing services or
Goods in Sudbury or Hadley or laam that
hasn't had to increase its costs for its
goods and its services and if it's done
so at a very low level I think most
people have generally been prepared to
accept that I certainly am I saw P pint
of mil onale in my local C for a pound
yesterday now I can recall when it was
not a lot less than a pound less than
50p I'm trying point I'm trying to make
is there have been massive cost
increases far in excess the cost of
running a car is high enough we know
that but the cost of running a car is
made up of a lot of things there's the
car itself depreciation petrol traveling
from one place to another uses fuel
which has a cost car parking of all the
costs people pay including insurance and
everything else is a tiny fraction of
what it costs to run a car I would
suggest reasonably that if you can
afford to run a car you can afford a
pound or two in a car parking charge
that might not be the case though we are
jumping the gun here this is a matter of
bringing proposals through a process con
consultation Eng engagement on and then
proposals now here's the point we don't
have the proposals before us they won't
be out till Friday I don't know what
their proposals might be but I know the
principle and the principle is our
responsibility is to have a balanced
budget um I asked the question of the
residents of Sudbury and Hadley if they
have noticed anybody else keeping their
charges exactly as they were for the
last few years and I'd also ask the
question of if we are not going to do
this in order to present a balanced
budget
what stat nonstatutory service that we
provide at the moment are we going to
have to get rid of I would be very
interested to see where people's
priorities lie when the alternative is a
pound or two because that I believe is
about the level we're likely to end up
at so for the moment let the process go
through its it means there'll be a
debate we know that and eventually
there'll be a decision but we haven't
done the process yet so let's not jump
the
gun thank you Council mcra um and I can
uh confirm that Council mcra does
photograph car parking tar boards he
sends them by WhatsApp messages to me um
and
uh he
does okay uh members of the cabinet does
anyone else wish to say anything more
councel potty yeah go on just said that
I I do welcome the IDE of the
consultation going as far and wide as it
possibly can I will say that I only live
8 miles from hadle myself as personal my
car is my only choice of motor travel so
this this consultation as it goes as far
as the demographic it can that is a
welcoming thing so therefore it would be
be a good um idea to have that put
through um it would clear the haze I
think we we're all under a bit P of how
it will will all affect us in the long
run but I will say as well that uh we
all in our council tax subsidize things
we may never use but we can actually
help steer our Market towns in B forget
about everywhere else St but in b as
much as we we can provide for them at
this crucial time as I mentioned before
about uh just in the recovery of the co
pandemic thank
you cast
s um can I ask the director of
operations um how we can strengthen on
street parking for res
residents um I believe that county has
the decision making power on this um but
um can we be assured that uh as a
council will'll Lobby the County Council
to get their support if we have to put
in Residence
permitting uh yes is the answer to that
we'll be happy to work with the County
Council obviously they're struggling
with um it's well publicized their
current um budget position but yeah
there's a there's a fairly prescribed
process for looking at residents parking
zones um and on on Street changes
despite what people think and logic
would sort of think this is doesn't take
much change and doesn't cost very much
they do tend to be quite expensive and
can be challenging from that point point
of view um and there's a process of um
gaining um public support for such
initiatives as well you tend to find the
residents parking zones start with some
interest but then when people find
there's a actual charge for the permit
and there are some restrictions that go
alongside the permit there is less
interest then and um so you so you need
to be clear on any success criteria but
that's certainly something that we could
um that we could look at we' be
absolutely transparent we're not we're
not sitting here as officers saying if
this came in there would not be it would
be absolutely perverse for me to say
there would not be a car that goes out
of these car Parks currently parking
free of charge and goes and parks in an
area which you can find that's free of
charge but there's nuisance parking
going on in different places on street
at the moment as well that we're working
with colleagues in the county to try and
solve as well um but there can be some
benefits as well thank you Council Derek
Davis my question is for Mark as well if
that's okay will the consultation um
take in the fact that obviously the
towns really love their car Parks um
that they actually apart from Hadley
don't have a general power comp so we
not able to but actually buy the car
Parks themselves and therefore you know
they can then manage them as they want I
appreciate in the early part of the
paper you said that it wouldn't go to an
external in other words it wouldn't be
NCP because of the various issues with
that but is it possible that the towns
could take on the car Parks or a town
that laven
and it's it's not something it's not
something that we've really considered
at this point if I'm totally honest but
um there's obviously clearly anything is
possible um to look at um from from that
point of view you have to look at what
it means for the district council I
suppose in terms of the uh overall
budget position position and closing the
deficit and we need to do this piece of
work on the finances because the 425 as
as um chair has been clear of how that
is broken down that is a budget position
there and we need to look at the full
liabilities of the car parks that
doesn't include all costs and that we
haven't done that deliberately because
we tried to put out early coms on this
when the budget position the budget
position emerged and it emerged that
this would be something that we need to
um look at we put that coms out before
Christmas wanting to be transparent that
we weren't sneaking a report out or
something just just before Christmas and
um yeah we we haven't got to that stage
yet we're waiting for this
recommendation to do the next St stage
of work and we'll bring the bring the
report back to um on obviously before
bringing it to uh cabinet if the
recommendation is agreed
today okay um I think we probably
exhausted the debate oh Council Carter
one last thing y just quickly sorry um
just because we've discussed it is it
possible
to adapt change the recommendation so
that the consultation is wider rather
than just the the four Town parishes
would you like to propose that may I
have a second councilor mcra I'm happy
to accept
that just for clarity what what is meant
by
wider I would suggest that since the
district as a whole has been subsidizing
free car parking for three hours I think
the district as a whole is a reasonable
suggestion obviously it's a going to be
largely an online consultation the
facility is there to do this it might
might increase and should increase the
number of responses is that a reasonable
thing is that a practical uh suggestion
given the time scale I think in in terms
of um sort of Engagement that the
director of operations is proposing that
talking directly to the uh towns and
parishes affected to to work on um uh
tariff options that's one thing but um
in parallel with that we can invite
comments through online means so emails
or whatever um from from elsewhere in
the district does does that kind of make
sense it could in could include a
general Global email to all parish and
town C all Parish councils effectively
because we' and we can do that as as
Council that could be done an invited
response from each Parish Council um
having stated what the proposals might
be and whether they wish to make any
response so if that would be the means
yes yeah we can work on the detail on on
that um but uh in terms of um today um
if if we make it clear that um in the
recommendation that we will uh consult
and seek opinions from across the the
whole District um I think that should be
sufficient for um the recommendation
modification today this District alone
this District alone yeah yeah I mean
there's no point we we we don't want to
include it s or mid suffk or west suffk
or brain Tre or culture store or any of
the the neighboring and that that would
just get far too
unwieldy don't ask us
no um so given that uh
sorry so chairman if if if it's helpful
so recommendation 3.1 if that simply
read carry out engagement and
consultation with the town and Parish
councils within
babber
yeah that sounds good and with other
recognized groups making representations
over the engagement period are we able
to amend the the recommendation online
so
yeah
amation and in the minutes I'll put
perfect absolutely perfect right okay um
so the the the um if we move to the vote
now unless anyone has anything else to
say um we'll have the that
recommendation will be amended um to to
read yeah so so we're going to agree the
amended recommendation 3.1
um the actual text of that amended
recommendation will be in the minutes
and it will reference um that the um
town and Parish councils with inv
vavor okay do you want me to read what I
think it says okay yeah go on so carry
out engagement and consultation with the
town and Parish councils within babber
and with babber counselors and with any
other recognized groups making
representation over the engagement
period yeah
perfect right we'll move to the vote
thank you chair that vote is now
progress
pleas thank you chair that seven votes
for that's unanimous thank you excellent
Right Moving on then um we're now going
back to item eight which is paper
B could I suggest a short break want a
short break yes 5 minutes just to we'll
have a minut break fible under the
circumstances
thank you welcome back everyone uh we'll
now proceed with the rest of today's
cabinet agenda so that means moving back
to item eight which is paper BCA
2332 the uh fees and charges list for
2024 to 25 um we do have uh on um
remotely accessing Karen Watling interim
corporate manager for finance Commission
in procurement uh Jack Burton uh Finance
business partner um and uh we've got
Tracy Howard corporate manager for
public protection here um and uh We've
also got Sean Coulter as well from
Finance team um I'm now as the cabinet
member for finance assets and
Investments uh it's my duty to introduce
this
report uh so this is the second of three
that I've got to introduce
today so I'm pleased to introduce report
BCA
2332 to cabinet which is the fees and
charges for 2024 to2 and this report
presents the proposed fees and charges
for a range of services provided by the
council including charges for services
governed by Statute and charges for
discretionary
Services these approved fees and charges
have been built into the draft budget
for 2024 to
25 now fees and charges are an important
source of income to the council enabling
important services to be sustained and
provided the council provides a wide
range of services for which it has the
ability to make a charge either under
statutary Powers set by the government
or discretionary when and those are set
by us the
council there are three to to remind
everyone there are three categories of
charging Services where there's a
statutary Prohibition on charging local
authorities must provide these free of
charge at the point of service generally
these are Services where the author
which The Authority has a duty to
provide bin collection is the prime
example of such a
service Services where there's a
statutary charge and charges are set
nationally and local authorities have
little and no opport opportunity to
control such charges income cannot be
assumed to increase in line with other
fees and charges planning fees fall into
this category and finally Services where
discretionary charges can be applied
local authorities can make their own
decisions on setting such charges
generally these are services that an
authority can provide but is not
required to provide these are things
like Garden waste and bulky items
collection and yes
parking service managers have reviewed
the fees and charges for their relevant
areas and given the pressures on the
general fund budget where possible fees
have been moved towards a model that
recovers the costs involved in
delivering service we have also where
possible Benchmark the fees and charges
against those charged by other local
councils to ensure cost recovery is
balanced with value for
money
for for the fourth coming year our fees
and charges are budgeted at £ 3.83 7
million which is 16% with the council's
gross
expenditure in order to sustain the
delivery of services in the future this
revenue is essential indeed income
generation is a key theme in our
medium-term financial
strategy with reducing Government
funding and limits on council tax the
stability and growth in the council's
fees and charges is a major part of
delivering this strategy
however this budgeted income is actually
a decreased at £
238,000 or 6% compared with the just
over4 million pounds that um we're
expecting in the current year and this
is driven by the drop in the volume of
planning fees which we're experiencing
at the moment and we which we expect to
continue through 2024 and
25 and these are only partly mitigated
by the um recently announced increases
of 25 and 35% in those fees
a breakdown of the income by service
area is provided in appendix B of your
report the proposed detail schedule of
fees and charges is shown in appendix a
and the changes are listed in the table
in section 5.8 for each the full cost
recovery is stated and you'll see that
this has been applied to almost all of
our fees in charges now the notable
exception indeed anomaly remains parking
income we we have as you know the
already discussed this um so I won't
mention it anymore
today the the table also shows the prop
uh proposed monetary and percentage
increases and I really would like to
thank our finance team and everyone else
who has put a lot of thought and work
into assessing all of our fees and
charges and coming up with a
comprehensive revision this year and
finally I'd like to propose the
recommendation in section three that the
proposed fees and charges for 2024 to 25
as shown in the appendix a be approved
and I'd like to ask for a seconda
please oh Council Sally
Davis right okay members of the cabinet
does anyone have any
questions councilor McCraw I just
spotted one percentage increase which I
believe is probably incorrectly stated
on page
15 dog breeders 1 to5 breeding
renewal it's going up 36 from
£183 to 219 States as 120% increase I
believe that's a 20%
increase you are right that's well
spotted there I'm a
nerd thank you for that um I haven't
checked them all but that one stood out
we will make a note of that and get it
corrected any other
questions okay um oh Council Derek
Davis
discussing know the importance of establ
establishing this as a foundation for
the rest of this administration's budget
because I I don't know if you agree that
we need to plan for the whole of the
next four years as well and it's
important that that we you know a we
approve this but then B we use this as
the basis moving forward do you agree
yeah I'll um defer to perhaps Karen or
or or Sean but um but basically yes and
we are setting uh the these season C uh
charges for full cost recovery as as
that basis um there are one or two where
we still haven't uh Gone the full way to
to meeting that and um we we will look
at addressing that as the next year or
two goes on for instance dog and
litterin uh collections um they although
they've been increased they haven't gone
up to full cost recovery yet you'll see
that from here but um
Sean did you want to add anything
further to that U not really as you say
we we've kind of calculated what full
cost recovery should be and in most
instances uh we've taken it to that
level um also just to make the point
that on some of the uh some of the
impacts we'll we've put a cost recovery
in there uh but the volumes are quite
low as well so when you're looking at
the the fees look at the volumes that we
process as well because some of some
don't exist like zies we've only got one
in the district so um and I think it's
only I think it's the dog bins mainly in
the lit bins where we're going to move
towards cost recovery rather than Go
full
in is there no more questions from the
cabinet do any other members present
have any
questions Council
Wyman thank you thank you thank you just
really quick question on the on the dog
bins we seem to be very reasonable I
mean is there do we have a basis from
which we actually derive that discount
for non full recovery you know is a
process that we consider from time to
time on what level of non full recovery
percentages we actually look at I think
and and I will ask for confirmation on
this um we we felt that um yes the the
dog and liquor bins have historically
been low um we do want to eventually
move to that full cost recovery but
doing it all in one go uh would have
been quite a burden on on uh our
parishes which which ultimately pay for
that um is that would you agree that's a
fair response to that yes absolutely
yeah thank
you just m yeah just on that point chair
I recall a couple of years ago I think
we we actually froze those charges for a
couple of years so um and I must say I
haven't had any uh push back from my own
Parish Council on this subject um
because I think we were rather better uh
rather lower than mids suuk were
proposing and unfortunately one of the
letters for uh mids was distributed to
some bber Council so there may be some
still some misunderstanding but uh
that's another question
okay if there are no further questions
then uh cabinet moving to debate does
anyone wish to make any comment about
this um are we happy with everything as
as it
stands in which case then we can move
straight to the
vote thank you chair that vote is now in
progress
thank you chair that is seven votes for
that's
unanimous
Right Moving on then item
10 paper BCA 2334 our plan for B and I
do have Joe Hobs the corporate manager
for strategic policy here to help answer
any
questions I will now introduced this
report as leader of the council and um
it is the last time I will be speaking
formally today thankfully
um right our plan for babber so I am
pleased to introduce report BCA 2334 to
Cabinet this is the coalition's plan for
Bava for the next eight years it sets
out our vision and priorities to 2031
the challenges we know we're facing and
how we want to approach them it has been
developed by the cabinet in the spirit
of collaboration a theme that runs
strongly in this plan as you'd expect
from a coalition Administration working
in collaboration across the Coalition
parties and with our communities and
partners the plan has been revised
following discussions with our
communities businesses town and Parish
councils partners and stakeholders over
the past few months starting from what
we heard when we spoke to people on the
doorsteps in the run up to the election
of course and then during the engagement
held in October to November we don't
know all the challenges we're going to
face in the next few years um and so we
have built in flexibility to respond to
these challenges the only have to look
at the last four years to see the
unexpected events that have happened but
what always shines out is that local
government has been at the Forefront of
responding to support our communities
whether it's through covid floods
whatever we also need to be flexible to
ensure that we meet the budget
challenges we are facing and you will
know by now that the message this budget
setting period is to be hon honest Bleak
we need to ensure we are working the
most effectively with for our local
communities to deliver what they need
and challenging financial times but our
plan for bab represents what we want to
achieve what we have heard our
communities say and what we know we need
our communities need need to continue to
ensure a resilient and sustainable
future for all our
residents I'd like to propose the
recommendation in section three that we
consider the feedback from engagement
and endorse the final plan setting out
the vision and strategic priorities for
Baba District Council 2023 2031 as set
out in appendix a and may I have a
second to please councilor saw thank you
members of the cabinet and do you have
any questions I know we' we've been
through this many times now so we're all
extremely familiar with what we have
here um so I'm I'm sure that you
probably don't have any
questions but other members of the
council here do any of you have any
questions you've had an opportunity I
know on on more than one occasion to to
review this
um if there are no questions then
members of the cabinet do you wish to
debate anything um is there anything you
wish to to say about our plan our
priorities Council mcro um counc Davis
Derek Davis and I was expecting both of
you to say something only to say we have
been debating this as a cabinet for some
months and we've come to a conclusions
we've lengthened it shortened it this
has been considered and and is a as a
view to the Future um it's not too
detailed uh but it's not too vague we
hope and that's the way we're
going yeah councilor Derek
Davis yeah I I'll repeat what I've said
in briefings is that these are fine
words and you know they really are good
but we actually have to make sure that
we do what we say we're going to do you
know and too often I think we find
reasons not to do what we put ourselves
down as the strategy and I think it's
important especially um because some of
the new things that are happening we
need to actually Implement that I'm not
agreeing but I agree that we should be
doing more walking and cycling and um
while I understand the importance of the
car especially in in the in the rural
areas you know when you're making
policies you need to keep that in mind
as well to make sure that we encourage
people to walk and and cycle and use
public trans
rather than drive 500 yards to a car
park thank you I I agree and and
realizing those Ambitions requires
money and we've been through that
several times today already Council
saw um thank you chair um I think one of
the
uh uh Central uh points about this is
that given um our financial position
which as we have said repeatedly is the
same as many other councils in the
country um we have to
be uh smart and we have to think about
as a council how do we change the way we
operate you know can we do more things
partnering with people because we don't
have as much money as we used to have so
you know we have to think about can we
be an enabler of other groups can we
bring other groups together can we use
the position of the council um to to
work with other partners because I
believe that that is the the future the
old what councils used to do and what
they used to be is is changing and um as
a council we have to move with that and
I think there are some things that we
have done already where we are you know
the first rural uh C the first rural
District Council to do certain things
and that's what we we shouldn't feel
that because we haven't got the finances
that we can we we should not be
ambitious we just have to think smarter
and I think we can do
that thank you councelor does anyone
else wish to to say
anything well we'll move to the vote
then thank you chair that vote is now in
progress um that is s Bas that's
unanimous that's carried chair thank you
item 11 paper BCA 2335 empty homes and
second homes policy um and we have uh
with us today Deborah Fenton director
for housing and Amma and yur the
corporate manager of Housing
Solutions and I will now invite the
cabinet member for housing to introduce
the report councelor Carter over to
you thank you very much um I'm here and
pleased to introduce this paper um empty
homes and second home
policy So today we're asking cabinet to
approve the empty homes and second homes
premium policy for
2425 the proposal for empty homes and
second home premiums policy aims to
address the issue of nearly 600 empty
homes in B the policy seeks to encourage
landlords to bring these properties back
into use by implementing higher council
tax rates for homes left empty and EXT
for extended periods of time it is
believed that the policy could help
tackle the shortage of housing alleviate
pressure on prices and make housing more
accessible for local residents who are
currently priced out of the market we're
doing this by working with landlords to
bring homes back into use by by using
services like houses for homes and
Central suff lettings we're looking to
encourage landlords to not any have to
not have empty homes wasting away but to
have tenants living in them therefore we
are proposing that anyone who leaves a
home empty for more than a year will pay
double the council tax three times the
council tax for more than five years and
four times the council tax for more than
years the idea is to give people a bit
of a nudge who have got empty homes to
work with us to get them back onto the
market if you look at
4.7 in your report it gives examples of
the exceptions on both the long-term
empty premium and second home premiums
being charged listed in previous
government
consultations proposals include if
owners serve in the military or if an
owner was genuinely trying to sell the
property the list will go on and it will
be published in full by the government
soon hopefully sooner rather than later
um initial analysis suggests that the
proposals for empty home premiums could
generate an extra 800,000 next year
between babber and mids which would
equal around 300,000 for bber um
regarding second homes there were around
570 second homes in favor and if the
proposals are accepted the owners of
those second homes would see their
council tax bill double from April 25
and the premiums for the second home
owners in 24 could net an additional 1.1
million in bber and nearly 2 million
across bber and msafer
combined the argument for those with
second home paying Council paying more
council taank is rooted in the principle
of fairness by owning multiple
properties individuals have access to
extra resources and services provided by
their local Council therefore it is
Justified that they contribute a
proportionate amount towards funding
these Services as they are benefiting
from them while potentially having
access to similar services in their
primary place of residents so to
conclude I'm hoping that cabinet members
have had the chance to look over their
papers as as it gives examples of not
only the money that could be earned on
empty second homes but the amount of
suitable homes that could be put back
into circulation with tenants living
inside of them which is something that
needs to
happen I would like to end by proposing
the introduction of the changes to the
empty Home Premium and introduce a
premium for the second homes and I
welcome any questions on the paper thank
you thank you Council Carter may I have
a second please Council Derek
Davis members of the cabinet questions
councelor Sally Davis and then councel
mcra um I'm just looking at um paragraph
6.2 on page 76 um do we mean babber at
the end of that paragraph when we said
um the income generated um by um second
homes would give us
£16,000 that should say B is that meant
to be B 61
where am I ah no you're quite right yes
it's got both both councils in
there right so that that's paper then
106,000 yeah
no
no no you you're quite right Council
Davis it should say
paper is that the right
Figure 6
6.2 okay yes no I'm just a bit confused
that's all Amma are you able to clarify
that oh Andrew would you be able
to yeah thank you Cher is a misprint
106,000 is
Bab right so so that needs to to be
amended then yeah okay
thanks any other questions Council m c
yeah yeah it's a very simple one I think
it's just a matter of clarifying the
recommendation in the key information in
uh par 4.2 um the uh original proposal
was for dwellings left unoccupied and
substantially UNF furnished for two
years or more would see the 100% premium
thus doubling council tax and I believe
that we're actually going for the
oneyear U
emptiness uh attracting the 100% premium
is that
correct that's my understanding but I
don't think it's it's been made clear
enough in the paper before we vote I
think it's
important yes so the proposal for the
empty premium we currently charge the
premium after two years so the proposal
is to drop it to charge after 12
months for the first section of par 4.2
is in fact one year
um that no what 4.2 is is doing is is
identifying what that um act uh 2018 act
um allowed with effect from uh 2019 so
it's it's background
information
yeah
okay there no other questions um other
members of the council do you have any
questions members of the cabinet back to
you for debate um I think we've
discussed this quite a lot we're all um
pretty happy with the proposal here for
both second and and empty homes um
certainly on on empty homes it will
encourage uh these to come back into use
um we have as we all know a shortage of
Housing and uh the idea of a substantial
number of homes lying empty is is just
not one that we can we can tolerate
quite
honestly I've got Council mcra councel
Dereck Davis and then Council Saul all I
say is I've had comments from people who
pointed out neighbors who have kept such
homes empty for considerable periods of
time time in the past and they've always
been able to dodge it uh by one means or
another I'm hopeful that we have means
to with the exceptions that we are
approving that we would be a little less
tolerant of uh mechanisms people have
used to avoid paying any
premium yeah Council Derek
Davis yeah just just to add really to
what you've said is I think this is an
excellent paper I think it's really well
put together and and there there's two
aspects
yes it bring income into baba but
hopefully not because hopefully the um
landlords will have filled their homes
and therefore we W be getting people
Neighbors coming in and complaining to
us as Ward members about why is that
house empty why is it being empty for so
long why is the garden such a mess so I
think this is double-edged and um we're
on a winner either way I totally agree
yeah councilor
sa thank you chair um I was um at a
parish council meeting uh last night and
um we discussed uh this particular um
policy and um the parish council was
very much for it um but um a question
was raised about um a a property um
actually in Hadley a a retail property
um that had been empty for quite some
time and the owner of this property
wanted to um turn into um a residential
property um but um for various reasons
he wasn't given planning permission um
and I know that
um I know that uh government has uh in
the past uh I've lost track of the
number of uh changes to government
planning policy but I do
recall in the last few months that they
had um spoken about commercial prop
property um being turned into
residential and I know um that uh that
isn't as easy as they might think um but
uh I I also think as regards uh this
particular uh policy I'm all in favor of
it but I also think that perhaps we
should look at um if possible and where
appropriate uh commercial and Retail
properties that could be converted into
um Dwelling
Places uh thank you Council S I think we
we can take that up with planning Team
Planning policy team see see what can be
done um through that mechanism to to
encourage that because you're you're
right
I sometimes yes we do want to keep
retail properties available for retail
use in high streets but it's not always
feasible it's not always the right thing
to do um and bringing people back to
live in our high streets is is no bad
thing either
any other comments from anyone councilor
Sally Davis is it okay if I ask another
question yeah go ahead yeah yeah okay um
I know we've got this um scheme is it is
it Housing Solutions where we we try and
get empty properties back into um to be
do we know that this council tax premium
incentivizes um people who own
properties to
actually put people in them do we have
we got evidence of what we do
ready being
incentive I don't
know Amma yeah Amma are you able to
answer that I mean we we have seen an
uptaking properties coming back into use
in terms of I think we've got about 26
or 27 units back into use and we've been
in touch with a lot of um empty home
owners and working with them to sort of
some of it is we can offer renovation
grants so definitely in bab we've seen
we have more take with the empty homes
team rather than in mid which currently
doesn't have the um empty homes premium
at the moment so we can see the distinct
difference between the two
districts okay if there's nothing
further then uh shall we move to the
vote we'll move to the vote thank you
chair that vote is now in
progress
thank you chair that is seven votes for
that's
unanimous lovely great thank
you right now we have uh next item item
12 paper BCA
um sorry that reference doesn't look
right BCA
2336 sorry uh the 2023 uh 2022 to 23
greenhouse gas report um has Sarah
Wilding climate change manager Anders
Chan the climate change consultant here
and I would like to invite the cabinet
member for environment to introduce the
report over to you councilor
Potter yes thanks very much chair uh it
doesn't feel that long ago we introduced
the last Greenhouse report so uh here we
are uh with the report for
2223 uh you'll see here that uh the
contents of the greenhouse gas report
emissions report on the pending s report
to be noted um since 2011 Department of
energy and climate change required local
authorities to measure report greenhouse
gas emissions from their estate and
operations each local Authority has been
requested to publish their greenhouse
gas reports locally online each year the
council is therefore required to note
this report's publication on the
council's website and over four years
the council declared a climate emergency
in this Administration and It produced
its first carbon reduction management
plan and a refresh of this plan is now
nearing
completion so this uh in the key
information the report covers a
comprehensive breakdown of the carbon
footprint for both councils in their
operations in 2223 provides detail of
the trajectory of the greenhouse gas
emissions since the establishment of the
Baseline back in 2018 2019 providing
supporting information for policymaking
Action planning to enable the councils
to respond to the Declaration of the
climate emergency and the commitment to
become carbon neutral in 2030 I just
want to note some changes from uh the
last report uh in terms of this latest
greenhouse gas report there are some
things worthy of know from that 21 22
report which are that greenhouse gas
emissions in
2122 uh stood at uh
47549 tons of CO2 emissions now to 2223
they have fallen to
3,882 tons of CO2 emissions that's a
drop around
18% uh scope one uh as you'll see in our
uh report uh is slightly higher in
2223 uh 53% compared with
46.6% in
2122 and in scope 2
23% uh is there in 2223 compared with
17.3% in the last report
2122 attributed to the impact of now
having direct responsibility for the
energy costs of all four Leisure centers
these are now transferred over from
scope 3 to scope to uh from gas
consumption and uh sorry gas consumption
now moving from from scope three to
scope one uh Leisure centers Remain the
biggest submitters however uh measures
um therefore have been put in place to
help reduce this we're presently
awaiting the results of the funding bid
by the end of January to increase such
measures uh going further forward the
2324 report is unlikely to see a huge
reduction uh because there have not been
any major interventions uh for the past
year however we may see improvements in
terms of savings from the Sola car ports
and it take time for those interventions
uh to bear
fruit uh the conversion of our waste
Fleet and public realm to uh hydrog
agent vegetable oil has had a notable
impact on reducing the CO2 emissions and
um I'm happy to report uh that switching
to HBO was even more effective than it
was originally anticipated on the
performance overall from the 22 23
figures this currently stands at
2.8% where it need to reach out uh where
it needs to reach to the 2030 Net Zero
Target we will therefore need to see
reductions on average of uh 53 tons of
CO2 emissions that's 99.1% reductions
each and every year to make sure that we
reach this target for
2030 the climate change team are
beginning uh to unpick the various C of
assets to see where we can make
greenhouse gas emission Savings in
addition to monetary savings we are in a
much stronger place with uh members of
the team carrying out robust analysis of
Effectiveness for example in our SOA
PV uh there will be a next round of
public sector decarbonization funding uh
which is in phase four uh which begins
later on this year the climate change
team are actively seeking what we can
potentially bid for in that round and uh
that concludes my
introduction and propos the
recommendation course yes thank you uh
councilor Potter I'm I'm really pleased
that the hoo has been more successful
and even we our best hopes so that's
that's good may I have a second please
Council
Carter anybody got any
questions councelor Derek
Davis we gonna is Brad Brad's still here
Brad's here
yeah there he
is I'm sure he's made I'm sure he's made
a note yeah because it is a good news
story yeah
yeah councilor mro yeah I it is is
something worth making a fuss about um
looking at the chart on graph nine and
they're sort of ups and downs but we're
more or less on the right trajectory the
the Baseline of the dra the the
direction of travel is right and we're
as it were back on track but we could be
said to have picked off the low hanging
fruit through H and do we have um any
immediate plans as to where the next big
chunk of the reduction could come and I
know we've only got six years so I think
it's a fair question to be asked and it
should be asked and I know it's a tough
question so I do apologize to councelor
Potter but that's what we're here
for yeah of course councilor mcro um yes
I would like to see more is in that HBO
um in those figures of course we we we
can see the gains already in these very
early periods um but for more sort of
detail I'd like to defer to um climate
change manager Sarah Wilding for more
analysis on that HBO question
you thank you chair I'm trying not to
lose my voice so I hope you can hear me
um yes so the refresh of the carbon
reduction management plan that's going
to Cabinet in March will ID identify the
priorities that we've made for
2425 um you're quite right in
identifying the fact that that HBO has
achieved um hugely
and um obviously we need Capital funding
for any sort of large scale um changes
that we need to make so the priorities
that we're looking at um hopefully we'll
be able to um secure funding for those
so fingers
crossed I ask supplementary on that
point because I mean it's relevant um
when it comes to funding we come back to
money again don't we but um we always
do is it correct then I'm just asking
this particular it seems to me that one
of the possible routs for the maximum
reduction is going to be through a
rather healthier HRA that approaching
our housing stock might be the best way
that we have to uh affect our carbon
emissions and I just wonder if that if
I'm correct in my assumptions and I
should add yes I have been on the carbon
management reduction scheme meetings but
uh I think it's worth bringing out in a
public
meeting um I'm happy to answer that um
so hopefully you've seen on the report
that our biggest um greenhouse gas
emitter is our Leisure centers followed
um shortly by sheltered housing so um
that is something that's on our radar
that um we we need to identify in terms
of our funding packages so hopefully
when the um next public sector
decarbonization fund opens we can look
at
that but we have to match fund it by 50%
as well so it's something that we need
to be aware
of that um it has been a constant team I
think as well in our G production
management uh plan that we we've uh
We've endorsed and we've sent through we
we've met together and it in the housing
in stock that we have we we would look
at all kinds of ways if we could
possibly retrofit properties that would
be grand obviously but uh it is a very
high priority indeed so it's something
we do take seriously and just so that
you're aware the there is a a social
housing decarbonization fund bid going
in at the end of this month
thank
you councilor Sally Davis this is a bit
of a general question but um I'd just
like to know the the opinion of Sarah
and Minaj that um it can be it can be
very easy to get downhearted about this
sort of thing that and I know you're
working in an extremely difficult
environment but are either of you
optimistic about our chances of of
getting to the Target in time okay
determined quietly determined actually
no noisily determined excellent even
better we will do our
best thank
you does any other member present have
any
questions yeah coun W go on just going
back onto the point chair in connection
with the social housing stock um some
social housing as as councelor marar and
I have witnessed there's a big
difference in the quality of our social
housing uh some will be good and some
will be less good um is it Our intention
to undertake an audit of the entire
profile of our housing stock at the same
time as looking at the the point that
Sarah's raised regarding the um the
decarbonization budget we are
undertaking an audit um uh Council
Carter do we have actual do you have
timings on how when that's going to be
completed
or so uh the projected thank you the
projected Target we we're trying to get
it done sooner we're trying to push for
it to be done sooner um but the sooner
the better so we know what we're working
with right over to the cabinet for
debate does anyone wish to say anything
um that as ever is is comprehensive um
it's uh it's given us a huge amount of
information and and it's great that we
see this on such a regular basis it it
does um allow us to to track everything
we need to track on on this and uh I'm
very pleased that uh Sarah is noisily
optimistic about enthusiastic
about um are hitting our Target and uh
we will make sure we do everything we
can so uh having said that let's move to
the vote then shall
we thank you chair that vote is now in
progress
thank you chair that is some VES for
that's unanimous thank you so moving on
to the last item um this is item oh
paper item BCA
2337 confiden uh confirmation of the
confidential minutes of the meeting held
on the 4th of December 2023 you find
that starting on page 113 of the agenda
pack if there are any points on accuracy
we will need to go into confidential
session so does anyone wish to raise any
points uh of accuracy on this
minute in which case we won't need to go
to confidential session and we can go
straight to the vote
need propos second oh sry right we we
need a pro proposal and second may I
have a prop coun mcro are you proposing
I'm happy to propose chair and oh sorry
no but I'm I'm happy not
to I
think minute oh do we need to go into
confidential session then yeah I think
so
do you want to do that Council s
yeah
yeah um okay
then exclusion of the public terms which
includes the press to consider whether
pursuant part one of schedule 12a of the
Local Government Act 1972 the public
should be excluded from the meeting for
the business specified Below on the
grounds that if the public were present
during this item it is likely that there
would be a the disclosure to them of
exempt information as indicated against
the item the author of the report
proposed to be considered in part two of
the agenda is satisfied that the public
interest in maintaining the exemption
outweighs the public interest in
disclosing the information may I have a
proposal for that
exclusion I thought it was Deborah
proposing and my second and Council mcra
seconding um so can we conduct the vote
to go into confidential session please
we can do that by share of hands
right
that